it was obviously disappointed is that
really just really in this day and age
one of the most appalling nights I've
seen in football racism has blighted the
beautiful game for decades from John
Barnes being pelted with banana skins in
the 1980s to Nazi salutes in the stands
at when England played Bulgaria in 2019
it isn't going away but Cam footballs
racism problem actually be solved people
have tried to kick it out of the game
for years but nothing has really worked
officials have been criticized for not
fining teams enough in 2004 FIFA find
the Spanish FA the equivalent of 44,000
pounds after England players were
subjected to monkey chants in Madrid
Millwall were only found 10,000 pounds
by the FA in 2019 after their fans
chanted racist abuse in their game
against Everton to put all this into
context hood ass field
town got a fifty thousand pound fine for
a stunt that advertised a betting firm
so what else is being done UEFA is
introduced anti-racism protocols but
could see more games abandoned matches
have also been played in partially
closed or empty stadiums anti-racism
group kiki tau have called four points
deductions and tournament ex portions a
group of black and ethnic minority
footballers including Raheem Sterling
have called for harsher punishments for
racism on social media and more be AME
people in positions of power but despite
decades of attempts to get rid of it
racism in football remains a huge
problem and it doesn't look like it's
going away anytime soon
[Music]